to our um
thursday research conference which as
you know we have
continued into the virtual era
although we miss the fun of being in
the vic theater so it
gives me a great honor to introduce
a longtime friend and colleague of mine
dr steve lavkov
who um has
who is a physician by training he
trained in cardiology
um he also uh trained in informatics
um at the same place i did a number of
years ago i think he came a year or two
after me
um we both trained under bob greenes at
brigham and women's hospital in boston
in informatics which was
which is part of the harvard medical
complex
steve has followed an industry path he's
worked for a number of companies over
the years a couple pharmaceutical
companies he's also been involved in a
lot of
entrepreneurial activities and so
brings a nice industry
focused perspective to his talk
most recently and now he is chief data
officer
for the multiple myeloma research
foundation
and he leads their bioinformatics
department that's responsible for
architecture
execution and management of all of their
data assets and um he
um is going to talk to us today
uh about the work that he does
and um will also give us some insights
into um his industry
perspective on informatics
and so i will turn things over to steve
you should be able to take the screen
and um
show your slides yep one second let's uh
hopefully this will work we tested it
beforehand
yep let me just put this on macro view
great hopefully this is sharing properly
it looks fine to me thank you bill uh
yeah bill and i were in a different era
at this point we uh
bill was in the early 90s i was in the
mid 90s and
i actually wasn't even clear i could
make a living at informatics when i
started it was a
a random encounter with one of bill's
colleagues jim mcclay who actually got
me into informatics
at an indian meeting back in 1992
and it wasn't for a random chance
meeting with of
uh jim mcclay and him giving me his
business card i never would have met bob
and eventually
bill and everybody else in the field i'm
going to talk to you today about some
work i'm doing
uh in the multiple myeloma space
as bill indicated i'm a cardiologist by
training i'm not a hematologist or an
oncologist
but this work uh revolves around
a lot of big data questions and problems
and we've
really encountered a ton of them along
the way and i'm going to talk to you
first about the introduction to what
what we've done and then
next i'm going to go through the uh the
registry and how it works
and then the challenges that we've hit
and the challenges are really varied
they
they run the gamut from um typical
informatics issues to
legal to regulatory issues uh
to some issues around you know how
people actually pack and
address boxes and i'll get into all
those things
so who are the who is the mmr the mmrf
is
a research foundation that's been around
for the last 22 years
it has been it was started by a woman
named kathy giusti kathy
is currently our chief mission officer
she herself is a myeloma survivor
back in the day when she was first
diagnosed
she was fortunate enough to have a cis
twin sister
and access to some early drugs in the
myeloma space and
she unlike most others survived
and when she got past her disease or got
through it
she decided to start this research
foundation to try to answer questions
that really weren't being answered in
the typical academic setting
so the mmrf works a little bit more like
a business than it does
an academic institution although it does
have very strong ties into academia
we have three main goals at the moment
and they're revolving around you know
oncology and genomics
a second one is how do you support an
organization like this through venture
and so the mmrf actually has started and
is running its own venture capital fund
uh the profits from which are pulled
back into the mmrf to help
sustain it uh and then we also have a
third pillar which is the one i'm
involved in which is
democratizing data so that patients can
understand and leverage it for their own
purposes for their own therapy and their
own disease course
um we work
off of a strategic plan this was a
project that was put together with some
help with
folks from iqvia they helped us actually
build a formal plan like we would have
built when i was at pfizer or at
astrazeneca
and those three pillars are are part of
it
we have a host of advisors from all over
the country in some cases the world
and they really run the gamut from uh
academia through
industry mmrf actually can proudly say
that it's been behind
or at least in part responsible for
bringing more than 11 new drugs to
market
and when i say in part it is either
provided data
or grants or other types of work in kind
to help advance these drugs it currently
is focused in on
various clinical trials that in itself
sponsors and others that it supports
in multiple different domains including
anybody's
bites and car t therapy
so as the cure cloud matu
sorry as the mmf maturity started to
realize it was really really good
at generating novel data sets and
early on it was the organization that
actually
caused the myeloma genome to be
sequenced
well this is going back almost 15 years
and because of that that was
one of the first cancers to actually be
decoded and that data was then used
by life science companies to actually
help them looking for
new compounds and bringing those to
market um
eventually it evolved to do one of the
longest studies
that's out there in myeloma called the
compass trial the compass trial is
ongoing it's got 1154 patients
in it unfortunately not all of them are
still alive uh only about 640 are still
are still with us and it's been running
for the
since 2011. uh that trial has
basically been following clinical data
of these patients as well as their
genomic data
for the last nine years and
it's scheduled to come to a natural
conclusion in 2023
but before it does we're going to be
doing immunoprofiling on all the
patients within the compass study
and i'll talk about that in some detail
a little bit later because it
involves what we're doing in cure cloud
eventually they put together a few other
studies at the university of michigan
where they actually got another thousand
patients
uh and their specimens uh genomically
sequenced
and then that led to another clinical
trial which is not represented here
called
my drug which is a gene testing out
genomic
um genomic variants
for various clinical trial arms so my
drug
is a platform trial and it has sort of
works like
various cassettes you can drop in a
cassette for a specific drug
with inclusion exclusion criteria and it
uses all of the
existing infrastructure for the trial so
you can bring a new
we call them cassettes into the program
as you go
and this is one of the first trials
looking at genomic
sequencing is an inclu genomic
aberrations as
an inclusion or exclusive criteria for
these arms
so that's an ongoing trial work there
actually led to what i'm working on
which is called the cure cloud which is
a direct to patient registry
which is being built and stood up to
actually bring in
data around 5000 patients for clinic for
myeloma
and i'll go into all those details as we
proceed so what actually is the care
cloud
well its overreaching vision is to
provide the most comprehensive
data resource for patients clinicians
and researchers concerning
the diagnosis and treatment of myeloma
and to fill facilitate a cure for every
patient
so that's a wonderful high 50 000 foot
view
but let's unpack it a little bit so what
is it actually what are we trying to do
from a goals and objective perspective
we are trying to recruit 5000 patients
with active disease
4 500 of which will have
um active myeloma 500 of which will have
a smoldering myeloma and for those of
you who are clinicians you might recall
there's
various different phases of the disease
in its lifespan
you start off with mgus which progresses
in a handful of cases
to uh smoldering myeloma which
eventually goes to full blown multiple
myeloma
and then you enter into the realm of uh
the disease and its
recurrences and all of the therapies
needed there
um we are planning on collecting and
returning clinical genomic data to
patients
through means of a 70 gene
myeloma-specific panel
through blood biopsies
which is a fancy word for a tube of
blood uh
that tube of blood is a special stretch
tube which is actually able to isolate
free circulating dna that dna is
is expanded through pcr and it's run
against the 70 gene panel
uh we are also saving uh three vials of
blood from the assay
for future work including
immunoprofiling and on top of all of
that
we're getting broad consent from the
patients to actually abstract away
or extract out all of their clinical
data from their ehr
where it's relevant to myeloma and we're
building a clinical repository
of uh patients in a longitudinal fashion
every six months we're actually querying
their electronic health records uh
and bringing more of that data to bear
to build this out
for the long haul um
using that 70 gene panel we're going to
be matching patients to clinical trials
that have a genomic component to them
right now there aren't all that many
there's about six or eight of them
but if the patients have the right
genomic sequence or not sequence of the
right genomic makeup
uh they will be uh given uh sort of a
direction to hit
hit up the pis and try to get themselves
enrolled
we're also creating a data set that will
support research and development as well
as health outcomes research
within life science organizations and
this is actually a really crucial piece
of the program
because it's through this piece of the
program we hope to be able to sort of
self-fund what we're doing
this is a 40 million dollar venture and
it is apparently
100 funded through uh donations from
patients
some of those patients happen to be very
wealthy thank goodness and their
their donations have brought us half of
what we need but in order to sustain
this for the next 10 years
we do need to find ways to leverage the
data assets
uh to help keep it keep this thing going
and at the end of all this we're going
to be building you know
a data set to provide both both
patients clinicians and researchers a
very high quality data set for
for their research and for their
clinical care all this is expected to
run
a minimum of 10 years and is
been my every waking moment for the last
two years
see here so
um what's the registry mechanically
uh if you double click on it yet again
it's a
it's a massive data collection workflow
management engine
um the data repository is as i said
meant to
collect information for these patients
and then we have portals that are
either up or being built that will
provide access
to the constituencies for their use
for patients we have visualizations data
visualizations we have
access to patient support documentation
we have a clinical nurses that actually
call the patients every three months and
take notes on them and their and where
they are in their disease and we keep
that in a separate portion of the care
club
for clinicians we provide them with this
with a clinical genomic report
that's uh read out by the pathologist at
the dana-farber cancer institute
and for researchers the research
database will be made available for uh
use once we hit approximately 500
patients that have walked through the
entirety
of all the workflows we actually
need to bring in at least seven
different types of actually matched
data and the match piece is actually
quite important in many cases when you
try to aggregate data across multiple
data sets the patients it's not always
easy to get
exactly the same patients data and you
need to resort to things like
probabilistic matching
in the case of the cure cloud but the
with one exception
all the data will be actually matched
the one exception is we're going to
cross that bridge
sometime at the end of next year which
is um
medical claims uh from payers and we're
hoping to get that match data there
we're unclear if we'll be successful
just based upon how they
make data like that available
so as you click down even further this
is sort of a high level workflow of what
we've built
basically a patient comes to our front
door they sign up they run through
inclusion exclusion criteria
if they meet inclusion criteria they
sign a very uh
deep patient consent with that is broad
broad consent
uh they answer a survey which gives us
some malicious demographics and some
information about their journey today
then we
have a phlebotomy company that sets up
a blood draw and this is a level of
complexity that
is part of the program they send the
phlebotomist to the patient's homes
and i'll explain why we do that in just
a second um
because in cova that's turned out to be
actually a really good thing
um but we didn't know it at the time
when it was planned we also when the
consensus
signed we send off the patient's name
and the consent and hipaa consents
off to a third party who then does ehr
data abstraction for us
uh the phlebotomy company goes off they
draw four tubes of blood one goes off to
the broad
uh where the 70 gene panel is run and
the other three go to the mayo clinic's
biobank in arizona
where they sit in for us to use at a
later date
when the 70 gene panel is actually
completed all of the bam files and bcf
files and all the accompanying
files that go with that get transferred
to the data farber
where we have clinical pathologists who
actually read all these files looking
for
the calls variant calls in the panel
they sign off on an actual genomic
report
which is sent back to us we send that
report off to the clinicians
and most importantly uh we send the
report off to a genomic counseling
organization
which digests the report into eighth
grade english
and i mean that quite sincerely it's
written at the 8th grade reading level
and that report is returned to patients
so
they're able to make use of it and
understand the depths of
what all this means and that report is
sent back to the patient
all of this is kept inside of the cure
cloud data system which is actually a
distributed set of databases
that are linked we have the ehr data we
have all the clinical genomic data
we have the patient reports the genomic
reports and those in gray are planned
for next year and the year after which
will be patient reported outcomes
immune profiling claims and of course
our clinical nurses notes
uh but those will never be made
available until we can come up with a
means of
of absolute de-identification um
we have all of this
uh has been two years or actually more
than two years but since i got here
it's been the last two years of my life
building this with a number of partners
and we stood this up and opened the
front door on this on july
14th of 2020 inside the covent
uh pandemic and i'll tell you about all
the challenges that have happened in
there
not the least of which was our
phlebotomy company went chapter 11
three days before we opened and we had
it sort of jump through a bunch of hoops
to replace them
uh in the month of july you might ask
yourself why did we pick 5000 patients
well when you start the the
one of the main findings from compass
was that there were
uh 11 or 12 uh genomic variants
or genomic findings or subgroups or
subtypes that were
part of the compass data set and you'll
notice that i have here
various weightings in terms of how
frequently they turned up within compass
in the really ugly lime green color in
the
second column we also wanted to break
this down according to where they were
in their journey
so we have newly diagnosed uh relapse
one two and three plus
if you break those down according to the
percentages and according to the
end of what we expect to see we wanted
to see if we could get patient
numbers and cohorts that were at least
40 for
study and if you do that at a thousand
most of this
heat map here turns off turns out to be
red even at 2 500 there's still a lot of
orange and
more green but when you hit 5000 uh
the model turns mostly green now this
isn't the only way to slice and dice the
patients it's not the only way to slice
and dice
these cohorts but it is one that from
our compass work
seemed to be one of high importance and
this
was one of the driving factors in uh
getting us to these
to these numbers so we're not doing this
in a
in a vacuum we're doing this alongside a
number of
academic uh institutional uh advisors
um we have uh an old friend of myself
and of
bills uh charlie saffron's one of our
advisors we have folks from ash
from msk um
while cornell and a bunch of others here
who are academic advisors
and they have different positions that
involve
uh odyssey and and other uh
relevant research efforts we also have a
life science advisory board for
companies that actually have an interest
in myeloma
who provide us with input in terms of
what their long-term needs are going to
be
in terms of how we build out the data
set and how we
provision it for their use um
we're trying very hard to work towards
common data standards
uh being uh my one of my previous jobs i
worked at
uh intelligent medical objects a company
that both
that bill's aware of and i'm sure many
of you have heard of i have a very uh
soft spot for using all standardized
vocabularies and ontologies
we're actually participants on omap for
oncology
which is part of the odyssey program
we're trying to help bring
some standards into that area we've
examined m code i'm not clear we're
going to go with m code or code for m
code just yet
it's an asco standard that's trying to
evolve unfortunately
for us it's more of a solid tumor
standard
for data nomenclature and ontology it's
probably not one we'll take on just yet
we are working with ash to try to make
our registry and their right they have a
myeloma registry as well
we're trying to make it so that um users
of each could actually crosswalk back to
the other
uh through an anonymized token mechanism
so that we can complement each other's
work
so uh we did open for research mode
in fall of 2019 we ran about 200
patients through that
and we have um
but the research mode wasn't doing one
of the work one of the real core
uh missions for the program which was to
return data to patients
for that we needed to get our program
clia certified destiny
clia certified and the entire pipeline
had to go
go through clear certification and that
didn't get done by the end of
2019 but we did open for research
we collected the blood we did the
phlebotomy we started ehr data
abstractions and we
ran the panel on research mode um
as i said we ran about 200 patients
through that and then
when we opened in july this slide's
actually a little outdated now it's
october
we now have close to 300 patients who
have signed up
and have accrued as as requesting to be
participating in the program
um i didn't expect us to recruit this
fast we're recruiting it roughly
depending on how you count either twice
our expected
rate or four times our expected rate
since we have
a very complex consent process that
requires a physician to order the test
and then to sign off on it we have over
close to 600 patients who have signed up
but not
all their physicians have signed the
paperwork yet so we're working on
getting that going so we're close to 600
in this who are part of the study at
this point
since july 14th which to my mind is more
than remarkable
so where are we in terms of the um
our our road map uh again we opened in
2019
over the course of 2020 we opened in
july
we look to be bringing in pros and and
full exome sequences
uh as well as immune profiling and then
later in 22 or
422 if we're lucky we'll bring in claims
claims data
i mentioned earlier we'll have 500
patients with smoldering disease that's
going to be the source of our exome
sequences our next gen exomes whole
exome sequences
um and we're going to be following those
patients especially closely because
of those 500 some of them are going to
be
converting into myeloma and we'll catch
their journey unlike with compass we'll
catch those patients
from the very very beginning of their
journey and
there's no reason we couldn't actually
increase these recruitments other than
we would just need more money so this is
the road map of where we're going
um at opening we've had four data sets
that are part of the system
uh the patient donated data that's part
of our demographic survey at the
beginning
our nursing notes the ehr data
abstractions which are bringing
it's a building a 24 table relational
database
uh that's updated every six months and
as well as the 70 gene panel
with the bam math files and all the
schematic mutation data that's coming
out of that
um so
we're about halfway through the talk and
i want to tell you that this has been
a an absolutely staggering amount of
work
uh to be to to happen um and
throughout all this it sounds maybe you
may sound like this was easy it was
anything but easy
we hit roadblocks in more places than i
could possibly have ever
guessed i've done very complex programs
in my career one of which was actually
building a hospital
in in kampala uganda once for pfizer
and i thought that was the most
complicated thing i've ever done
involving
you know traveling 8 000 miles and
working with the cdc and procuring
satellites and satellite
satellite dishes and time and raising
capital to do it
it turned out that putting that hospital
together was chicken
was just uh you know a cakewalk in
comparison to
this program and that's because this
program
involved an enormous amount of
regulatory and legal issues
uh issues around clinical data reuse and
extraction
the returning data to patients became a
tremendous
source of complexity for this program
and we'll go through we'll go through
all these in the next few slides
so one of our macro challenges was
basically
building this registry for all comers so
typically registries are built
by an academic institution or perhaps a
pharmaceutical company
they tend to work within the confines of
of of one institution a group of
institutions the first macro challenge
here is that we're trying to get data
from patients across the u.s
and as long as you met the inclusion
criteria you could participate
which means that we had to figure out a
way to get electronic health records
data out of
ehrs across the us and as much as i'm a
fan of fire and i'm a fan of
of being able to make those kind of
digital connections the reality of it is
is that in 2020
2018 through 2020 most of those
connections except for a handful of
large institutions
simply aren't ready for prime time
especially for types of data we're
trying to collect
some of the specialty data like fish
reports are coming in as faxes
or as pdf images and you just simply
can't get them
through the kind of interfaces that
we're hoping
we're hoping for the home-based
phlebotomy
program became a real challenge for us
things as simple as getting the the kits
shipped from the broad
having them labeled properly and having
them uh
tagged right uh involved manual workflow
and as soon as you introduce a human
being into a workflow like this
any number of weird things can start to
happen we've seen pretty much all the
weird things
that we think can happen but we're only
into it now again for the
what two hundred actually run um and
even in there we're seeing a three to
five percent
i'll call it a weird factor of weird
things that just happened so
an example of a weird thing that happens
is is that
we have some exclusion states we can't
run this assay this test in the state of
new york
in in alaska or hawaii alaska and hawaii
are simply
based on practical issues around um
fedex shipping we have to get the blood
into the broad inside of 24 hours
so it can be fractionated while it's
still good
so alaska and why fedex could not
guarantee us next day delivery
so we we mixed them on that basis new
york on the other hand
we had the knicks because it turns out
when you're trying to get clear
certification
new york has its own super clia
certification new york state
has its own uh review process for
getting lab certified
for patients who live in the state of
new york and it turns out because this
was a brand new assay
uh getting that certification was not
feasible
at the broad in time for this to get off
the ground so therefore unfortunately
for us
we're not able to take anybody from the
state of new york so among the weird
things that have happened we've had
patients who want to participate
who have houses who live in new york but
have homes in florida
so what have they done they have
literally set up even in the pandemic
to try to coordinate when our kits would
be shipped and the blood would be drawn
so they would be in their florida homes
in order to participate in the cure
cloud technically they can do that
as long as they have a clinical
physician who's not a new york doctor
who could write the order in florida
that's kosher
but anything in the state of new york is
not kosher for the time being we're
going to work on
solving that one but that was a bridge
too far to get opened um
other problems that we'll get into a
little more deeply had to do with moving
genomic files
between institutions between the broad
and the dana farber
you know that involved using systems
from from google
and a homegrown system from the broad
called terra that has to
communicate with a commercial system
that the dana farber uses in their
pathology department
to bring in those files and then make
those calls by the pathologist
that became another one of our
challenges and then creating
uh creation and agreement on various
data dictionaries and data models
and to try to use common standards where
possible
so we've been exploring as i mentioned
earlier the omop common data model for
oncology
which as much as we want to use it some
pac some aspects of
oman for oncology aren't ready for prime
time either so we've dug in
taking you know rolled up our students
we have members of my team
who are working to actually help bring
some of those standards to bear
so that model can be evolved
we had technical challenges with all the
various data handoffs we had to ensure
that
confidentiality and privacy was of prime
importance
in the background of this whole thing we
have a rosetta stone that basically
aligns all of the various identifiers
for the
uh for the patients in the system that
rosetta stone is encrypted and behind
firewalls
um and every one of our partnering
organizations has its own
series of unique identifiers for
patients within the system
it's only inside the system where the
patients could be
reconnected we had to put together sound
data stewardship
uh principles and execute on those
principles end user
as an example our end users who are
administrators we don't just let people
like email in and sign up we physically
have to lay eyes on them and know them
personally
before they're given access credentials
to administer anything within our system
um so even if you were to hack in with
credentials if you hadn't been known to
us
you wouldn't be able to just get in uh
workflow administration and data flow
monitoring is also a really key part of
this
we had to build a back-end
administrative portal for this so we
could actually watch
all of these different pieces of the
system and where people's data were
along the way so i talked about weird
things happening so
the one phlebotomist we have two
packages that go out
the package goes out with tubes that
have to be drawn and sent to the biobank
and tubes that have to be sent to the
broad institute
well naturally um even though we have
instructions and labels on two separate
boxes the tubes got confused
and so far in the in even in the real
version the clear version
that happened twice out of the first 24
kits that we sent out
so we have to accommodate you know
issues like that and send out fresh kits
and things along those lines
and i talked about common data models
from a legal and regulatory perspective
getting this clea pipeline certified
was really critical in order to return
data to patients
uh that's why we had to go with a clia
certified test well
having the clia certified test actually
has some knock on things we had to
address
so in order to get a clia test ordered
it has to be actually ordered by a
physician
well this had another knock-on effect
which was as we started digging on this
it turns out
that you needed to have physicians in
the same state as the patient
in roughly 18 states in the union
in 15 states it's actually illegal for a
doctor across state lines to write the
order for the blood test
in another patient another state in
three states it's ambiguous
and leaning towards the illegal these
laws turn out to be part of the
telemedicine laws
that until kovid were pretty restrictive
and as a result this took us some time
to figure out what to do
our solution for this ended up being
that um
we went we could have done several
things one of which could have been
hired doctors in all 50 states to be our
you know
physician writers but we thought the
better of that we actually have the
patients personal clinicians their
hematologists running the order
that way we can return the clinical
report back to that physician that can
help inform them for their patients
uh actual clinical care uh so that their
clinician gets the report the patient
gets the digestive report
and the two of them are hoping it'll
facilitate a better conversation about
their entry into clinical trials or any
changes in
their therapy based upon based upon the
data that we have here
another complexity was dealing with not
one not two but count them three irbs
uh because we work with um the ir the
the
mmrf deals with western irb which is a
paid irb or commercial irb
but because this program is being read
out
and it's a still clinical study and the
dana farber is involved we had to deal
with their irb
and again same thing with the broad
broad has their own irb
so very various stages of the game here
the protocols and various aspects of the
project had to
go through all these different external
checks
and balances which is not a bad thing it
just added to complexity
[Music]
i mentioned new york being problematic
and then we have another issue which
came to light which was
how we get the the medical
the medical records pulled so it turns
out that there's a
consent law that was put on the books in
2001
but not all the hospitals across the us
have heard of that particular law
and as a result they're refusing to
honor the patient's signed
digital consent roughly 20 percent of
the time
and that's another regulatory and legal
hurdle we're trying to cross
by you know strengthening our digital
consent and getting certified signatures
and things like that
so that's made that was another series
of confounders that we had to deal with
uh yet others
were around data reusability in the
abstraction data reuse and abstraction
so again we went through all comers
so that meant and we tried to go with
fire we tried to
figure out a way to to build pipes into
all these different places but since we
don't know a priority where these
patients are coming from
they could be coming from a doctor's
office all the way through to
the mayo clinic or cleveland clinic or
harvard
um you know building all the pipelines
at the moment is still a kind of
prohibitive exercise for us
as a result we hired a third party who
does this
they're actually getting back wait for
it
pdf files when they go and make these
requests and when they are getting them
back
they're getting pdf files at the
clinical record which then have to be
physically
manually reviewed and manually
abstracted for all the data that we're
looking for
that in fact is about a third of the
expense of this program
uh and that's you know we're plowing
through that one with brute force
and i know there's folks on the line are
going to say oh you know we should be
able to do this
digitally and i would wholeheartedly
agree and if you could show me a way to
do it across
all comers in a in a consistent fashion
please contact me after this talk i am
all ears
we would love to figure that piece out
and stop with the manual abstractions
it's a high expense and high
it's it's a very complex thing to have
to go through
we do have data dictionaries in the back
of all this this is just a screenshot of
one of them
we define in very low detail all the
different values and what the control
values need to be we've got them all set
up in a way that
the data as it comes in could be put
into uh into things like
r so we can do our own research and
visualizations on them
when it comes down to returning the data
to patients i think i've already
mentioned
this had to be a clia certified test uh
but also making sure that all the data
was sent around
through the different parts of the
pipeline in anonymized fashion required
us to hook up different
uh connection points uh between
large institutions and uh hooking up
these types of pipes between places like
harvard
you'd think between since the broad's a
harvard institution and so is the dana
farber
but that wouldn't have been easy well
that was a good six month exercise by
itself
um we had to build new api calls and
build them from scratch to make sure
that all the data was being sent across
properly and again i mentioned earlier
we get to monitor all the data flow to
ensure
that we're not losing records along the
way especially some of these large
records
[Music]
something as trivial as building a
clinical report the physical
report that that people are going to
have to read that had to be crafted from
scratch
the the the dana-farber pathologists and
the mmr
spent almost a year believe it or not
crafting what would physically go into
the report that the clinicians would get
and of course that had to go for irb
review and had to get
uh go in for the for the clear
certification
um and all the report automation pieces
had to be built from scratch as well
um and then finding a way to return the
report
back to the clinicians of record that
had to be built
and as much as i would love to send this
all back through
you know an encoded email some docs are
not giving us their email addresses so
we have to resort to wait for it
faxes and we had to accommodate faxes in
this workflow in order to make sure we
could return
data to patients appropriately this is
just a copy of our screenshots of the
clinical report from the broad
and the david farber and on the other
side of the screen is the my gene
council report this is a
this is the 8th grade reading level
report that is
going back to the patients
returning the data to patients was yet
another wonderful
exercise visualizing data highly complex
data that
is usable by patients again at the 8th
grade reading level
we had to bring in a separate firm who
whose job it was was to
ensure that all of the visualizations
were easy to understand
and very easy to digest by real people
as opposed to clinicians
or phds they went through rounds and
rounds and rounds of a b
testing with both clinicians and with
patients to try to hone in
on what would be the most advantageous
and easily digested approach to showing
patients this data
and that's still frankly work in
progress that's not even complete yet
the next couple screens are just a
couple of examples of some of these
uh the screenshot
that are in flight uh we're trying to
make
big big fonts and with large iconography
to try and make
this as as as human digestible as
possible
this one on the far far lower right um
we're trying to actually also do patient
journey
on on some of the temporal data so we
can actually show
uh when labs change over time we have
the lab data
we have their fish data we have their
all the abstracted information
so we can show this over time and give
them a view as to how their
uh disease is progressing at least as
we're seeing it through the chr
abstraction process
we have more views of that information
and confidentiality is obviously an
enormous
chunk of work on this program uh
everything that we do is
ssl encrypted we event end encryption
data is encrypted in motion and
rest uh all the identifiers are blinded
except for the data managers here at the
mmrf
and our and our uh vendor who's working
with us to build the back-end systems
the rosetta stone is completely
encrypted and
we have role-based security and every
single person involved here has to have
hand-approved access to the system
[Music]
we had to establish a project management
office
you know the last time i dealt with the
project management office of this
complexity was again
in africa and this was even more complex
we had to
when i joined the organization we had 14
different companies that the memorial
contracted with
to help build this thing we windowed
that down to eight
but even with eight that's still a lot
of people and pro programs and processes
to manage
it's actually enormous we had to do um
edge case generation and with multiple
whiteboard
sessions to figure out where different
issues were going to be
hit for exclusion for edge cases for
when something were to happen so when
the bro when the phlebotomist put the
label on the wrong kick
we had to think about that come up with
a way to
nullify that kit and resend a new kit
and take them out
you know reset the system so every
single little nit that had
that was possible to happen we tried to
pre-think and come up with all these and
come up with ways to deal with all these
different processes through the system
[Music]
um we built dozens if
you know if not a hundred different data
flow diagrams of how things are going
this is just one example
this is another this particular example
is just the first of nine
on the data flows and approvals
necessary this is just to get a patient
into the system uh and these all link
off to other sheets and so forth
and then of course the biggest challenge
of all which
was like a a bus hitting us from left
field was coving
when covet happened in march uh
all the work that was in flight of the
broad came to a screeching halt
we couldn't finish the validation of the
pleia test
it all literally stopped because the
broad was conscripted by the state of
massachusetts to do
all covent testing all the time for
about five months
they only recently came out of that and
have been
back to doing our work you know our work
and other work
in the research space probably since
only september
likewise dana farber closed for all
research programs
no patients were being accrued for any
study and our work was put on the back
burner for about three or four months at
the dana farber
as i mentioned earlier our home
phlebotomy company went chapter 11 due
to covid
on july 11th which required a rapid rfp
team to get into position try to bring
um
uh bring a new company online we
actually pulled that off
we we got quest uh subsidiary quest
diagnostics
to uh come to the table and they're now
our
phlebotomy company overall coveted set
us back
probably more like four months uh but
again the first blood kits went out on
uh the 14th of september and our
kits were returned the first 12 hit the
analyzers about two and a half weeks ago
and we're expecting next week to get the
first genomic tests off the analyzers
and over to the pathologists
start actually closing the loop all the
way through and returning this data to
patients
as we go here our program will have four
types of data
as we open i've mentioned the patient
donated data the
uh the nurses notes from the every they
call the patients every three months to
see how they're doing i think i forgot
to mention if the patients have a
relapse actually we're doing another
blood draw so we sort of
hit a big green button or a big red
button depending on your perspective
and that sets off another blood draw for
those patients we can seriously follow
their somatic mutations because in in
this situation unlike
a
unlike a germline mutation the patients
uh mutations tend to change with therapy
and as a result if you catch them
at different stages of their disease
before or after a given therapy line
you probably can we think we're going to
see changes in their actual somatic
mutations
so that's why we're going to the trouble
of actually getting that repeated
we have the ehr data which i've already
mentioned and then our data from our
genomic panel
in the years to come we're going to be
adding patient reported outcomes we're
going to be looking we're looking to put
in
the aortic um
qlq30 and my20
as patient reported outcomes we hope to
be bringing that online in early 21.
you pro finally will be a complimentary
series of uh
tests with uh scitov and single cell
rna-seq
information that will be on every
patient in the cure cloud
we'll have whole exome sequencing on the
on the patients who are in for
smoldering
medical claims later probably
realistically by 2022.
so and we opened the door this is the
front page of the system i'm not going
to do a system demo
uh today but if you go to
mmrfcurecloud.org
you too could do this and uh you know
only if you're a member
if you have the inclusion criteria but
you could go and take a look at what we
put together and it is up and working
i'll just add one thing when i joined
this organization um
to me this was you know the informatics
program
that would just be like this amazingly
complex thing to solve and i love
solving these types of puzzles
but this program got very very personal
to me
in march when my first cousin was
unfortunately diagnosed with myeloma
himself and
from that point he just had his
transplant about three weeks ago
so this program has gotten exceptionally
personal for me
it's not often that you work on
something like this and it hits home
in this kind of way but it um it really
has
come home in a in a painful way
to me so i'm going to pause here
and open up the conversation for
questions
[Music]
again if anybody by the way has any
ideas about anything i've talked about
or concepts or things that they
think could help us with this i'm going
to put my
my email address and phone number in the
chat box
um
that's my email address and my my cell
is or my i'll give you my
yeah myself if anybody has any
suggestions
for anything i've talked through here
today we are
not proud we will take any advice we can
get we are open to hearing
you know anything that would help us
make this easier because as you've seen
this has been
you know an adventuring complexity so
i'll pause there and i'll turn it back
over to bill to moderate questions and
answers
yeah great thanks steve um unfortunately
we we can't really clap well i suppose
we could clap virtually
no it's a very nice talk to hear
always good for me to find out what my
friends are up to and uh sounds like
you've been up to a lot i'm gonna make
two quick observations and and then a
question
i i see some accumulating in the chat
box and you can answer those as well or
people
can unmute themselves um a a couple
couple comments um one is that um
one of the nice things about your talk
as as i think you know we have students
who are
very deep into bioinformatics and very
deep into clinical informatics and
your talk and what you're doing is a
great example of how those
areas overlap and i think as time goes
on we're going to see more of that
a second observation is that um your
your your story of all the challenges
you faced um
uh remind us of that old adage that when
it comes to
informatics technology is the easy part
a lot of times it's dealing with
complexities with
organizations and people and so forth
and i think
i think you drive that home even though
the technology is very interesting
let me ask a quick question i don't want
to take up all your question time but um
the um um you know you're it's
interesting that you're starting to
import um ehr data and obviously that's
important although
there's a number of people listening
here myself included
who have spent time kind of thinking
about what we can actually do with
um electronic health record data
sometimes
it's incomplete because patients get
their care in different places sometimes
it um is inaccurate uh clinicians don't
track things right um
and so sometimes ex you know actually
having people extract or annotate the
data can can actually
um overcome some of those problems um
what do you hope to do in the longer run
with ehr data
to help inform your project so that's a
great question so one of the things
we've done and into another program i'm
running for
the um for mmrf it's a program with the
intermountain health organization
we actually built a clinical data
visualizer to actually look at
longitudinal healthcare data using
senkai plots
as one example where we actually could
take the
you know what we want to see we want to
map this to outcomes so what we really
want here
is the clinical information linked to
outcomes so then we can
show in the case of drug regimens as an
example
and i don't have it in this deck to
share but what you can do is
you can actually track the course of
their drug
therapy and their outcomes and what
different clinical states
they proceeded through so this will be
familiar to you bill
i actually have been working with
greenish with bob greenis on
work that we did way way back at the
brigham on clinical state mapping
so the clinical state mapping work the
greenness worked on back in the 90s
we brought to bear for this and we're
hoping to be able to identify clinical
states along their journey
where we could have a different
intervention that might actually lead to
a better outcome
so it's another piece of the
visualization that's meant for the
clinicians it's
part of a different program but that's
one of the one example of where we're
hoping to go with this data
you know you said that bringing the
clinical data forward
you know it's full of holes it's got
issues it absolutely does
and by the way one of the vendors that
we worked with i will i won't say who it
was
but as we were bringing we had more than
one vendor
uh involved with the clinical data piece
of this at the beginning
and one of these vendors actually uh i
found an aberration in their data
which was they had start dates in one
table but no end dates for most of the
drug regiments
that were being used but yet in another
table they had duration of therapy
so i called them on that i said how do
you calculate duration of therapy if you
have no end dates back in the other
table
which was in theory what they were
abstracting into
and it turned out and i still didn't say
can't believe it
but they were imputing end dates based
upon
what was in textbook information and
putting that in the data set
which made my mind want to explode and
we actually canceled the contract it was
a 5 million dollar contract and it was
canceled
because i don't know how many different
ways you can say you can't do that
but you can't do that and great
so yeah there there's a few questions in
the chat box i don't know if you can see
them or not
i can uh read them to you if not um
jennifer sullivan one of our phd
students uh thank you for sharing your
experience
how did you learn about the various
regulatory requirements for everything
you wanted to do
whom did you consult or what resources
did you use
yeah so the mmrf has a lot of um
organizations that has partnerships with
many of whom are actually lawyer for law
firms
um and one of those is a law firm called
ropes and gray a regulatory
firm out of washington dc and as
you know i've been around the
informatics world and in the business
world for an awful long time and some of
this stuff
i just started to sort of ask questions
and when we started asking the questions
it became well we don't actually know
then we went to robeson gray
who then found all these things up like
i would never have figured out
that the telemedicine laws were the laws
that govern a project like this but they
are
um and robeson grey gave us the whole
point of view that it was the 18 states
that you couldn't do this in the way we
envisioned we envisioned having our
chief medical officer
write all the orders and that would have
ended it all would have been much
simpler
but uh they told us you know you just
can't do that now
post covet it's going to be very
interesting to see if
some of those laws are sufficiently
relaxed so that we could go back and do
that again
but i think where we landed with having
the clinician of record
write the order is probably a really
good solution because
it actually helps bring the doctor and
the patient together and i think that's
a
you know although that's a really good
thing
yeah yeah i i agree with you i i think
the telemedicine laws are going to
change i mean it it's um
telemedicine's had a huge impact at our
institution for a while
over half of our visits um
so there's another question from chris
alpey who's the director of our library
and i'll read it what method did you use
to negotiate the disagreements on data
visualizations
would you recommend doing all the
multiple rounds of a b testing on
variations how many rounds did you do
so if you got all that i got it i think
she meant agreements not disagreements
uh oh maybe she met disagreements
yeah yeah i probably meant to see it
it's either or how did you get to
agreement
so i i won't lie to you this was i think
disagreements actually isn't is the
right word because we've had some very
heated discussions over the year
in terms of what to show what not to
show um
and you know i
i didn't run that particular part of the
program i
i had to delegate a lot of things in
here you can't imagine this would be
worn by one person we have a cast of
hundreds
maybe not hundreds of dozens working on
this program
but we had an external group come in
uh their names are the group is called
spring box
and they actually have uh they did a lot
of work
uh in the space of patient facing
information
uh and they are the ones who ran the a b
testing honestly i can't tell you how
many rounds they ran
but they did run several rounds of a b
testing on various
like every tile and the visualizations
that were in there
they were pretty much all tested uh but
i didn't run the piece of the project
and i
wish i could tell you it was you know
six rounds but i simply don't know
thank you sure yeah great
any other questions um if if not i'll
actually ask one more
you didn't say um anything about or if
you did i apologize if i missed it
um about clinical trials is is this
resource amenable
to clinical trials so this
is a clinical trial i don't i think i
mentioned that this is an nct id number
um we are in clintontrials.gov
and one of the outputs on the patient on
the patient report
which is uh let's say you get back there
there it is on the patient report one of
the outcomes of that report is a
clinical trial matching service
so there's really we find there's at the
moment there's about eight clinical
trials i think six six to eight clinical
trials
that have have output from cure cloud
that would be used as a inclusion
criteria for that trial
and if the patient meets those criteria
they are
shunted or at least given the advice to
contact the pi
to get into that trial one of those
trials is one of our trials it's the
one i mentioned earlier uh the my drug
trial so
you know maybe it's a little
self-serving but we are trying to find
patients for that trial too
okay yeah and and you know i know
there's a at our cancer institute here
there's probably others who know more
than i do but there is a kind of
precision medicine trial
that that um you know is basically
comparing people
using molecular approaches versus not
using them
right okay um any other
questions or comments
um
okay well seeing none i want to thank um
steve for um
sharing this uh very interesting project
with us
and um uh maybe uh down the road
as it uh matures and and
achieves more um things we can get him
to come back and
and give us an update so um
thank you very much steve and um uh we
appreciate you taking your time today to
do this
thanks bill thanks everybody have a nice
day yeah
you too